Bonjour à tous, aujourd’hui on va parler
d’un des concepts les plus troublants
de la mécanique quantique:
la dualité onde-corpuscule.
C’est le fait qu’en mécanique quantique,
dans certaines circonstances,
les particules se comportent comme des ondes,
et les ondes, comme des particules.
Vous en avez sans doute déjà entendu parler,
peut-être par moi d’ailleurs.
Et pourtant, avant la fin de cet épisode,
je vais vous parler d’une expérience
qui pourrait bien vous surprendre,
voire vous retourner le cerveau
concernant la dualité onde-corpuscule.
[jingle]
Le cadre le plus simple pour discuter
de la dualité onde-corpuscule,
c’est bien sûr de parler de la lumière.
C’est un phénomène familier, qu’on observe
en permanence,
et historiquement les débats sur la nature
de la lumière
ont fait couler beaucoup d’encre
chez les scientifiques.
Certains comme Newton pensaient
que la lumière était faite de particules,
d’autres estimaient qu’elle devait être
plutôt une onde.
Et le débat a été provisoirement tranché
au début du XIXe siècle
lorsque Thomas Young a mis en évidence
les interférences lumineuses.
On en reparlera dans l’épisode,
mais les interférences sont un phénomène
qui s’explique très bien avec des ondes,
mais qui ne colle pas du tout avec l’idée
d’une lumière faite de particules.
Le débat a ensuite semblé en rester là
pendant une centaine d’année,
mais en 1905, Albert Einstein a montré
qu’un autre phénomène,
l’effet photoélectrique, s’interprétait, lui
très naturellement en supposant
que la lumière était faite de paquets
d’énergie bien localisés: les photons.
Quelques années plus tard, le physicien
Louis De Broglie a formulé
de façon plus explicite la dualité
onde-corpuscule,
et on s’est fait à l’idée que suivant
les expériences que l’on considère,
les objets quantiques peuvent se comporter
soit comme des ondes, soit
comme des particules.
Ca peut paraitre assez invraisemblable
comme idée,
et pourtant si on prend un peu de recul
on se dit
qu’il n’y a finalement rien de très
choquant là-dedans.
Prenons un exemple issu d’un autre
domaine de la physique.
Vous avez certainement déjà vu
les expériences amusantes
qu’on peut faire avec un mélange d’eau
et de maïzena.
Si on a les bonnes proportions, on obtient
une substance bizarre
qui coule entre les doigts, comme un liquide.
Mais si on la manipule vigoureusement,
elle se travaille
comme de la pâte à modeler et semble être
plutôt solide.
Si on tape dessus violemment,
aucune éclaboussure,
c’est comme si on avait tapé sur un morceau
de caoutchouc.
Est-ce que pour cette matière étrange
on parle de dualité solide/liquide?
Non, on a finit par admettre qu’il s’agit
d’une substance
plus complexe qu’un simple liquide
ou un simple solide,
et qui, suivant l’expérience qu’on fait avec,
se comporte comme l’un, ou comme l’autre.
La dualité onde-corpuscule
en mécanique quantique,
on pourrait dire que c’est pareil.
Les objets quantiques sont des trucs
plus compliqués
que de simple particules,
ou de simples ondes,
et le comportement qu’ils auront dépendra
de l’expérience qu’on réalise.
Ce point de vue, c’était en gros
celui de Niels Bohr,
qui avait appelé ça « la complémentarité ».
Il disait que les propriétés des objets
quantiques n’existent pas dans l’absolu,
et ne se manifestent que quand
on fait une mesure.
Et le résultat va dépendre de l’expérience.
Pour revenir à mon exemple de la maïzena,
on peut dire par exemple
que la viscosité de cette substance
n’existe pas en soi,
elle va dépendre de l’expérience
qu’on va faire avec.
On ne peut pas lui attribuer de viscosité
si on ne dit pas d’abord ce qu’on est
en train de lui faire.
Avec cette comparaison, et cette idée
de complémentarité de Bohr,
je trouve que la dualité onde-corpuscule
parait soudainement
beaucoup moins extraordinaire que ce
qu’elle semblait au premier abord.
Et pourtant, tout à l’heure, on va voir
une expérience
qui jette un sérieux trouble sur cette
vision rassurante des choses.
Mais pour vous l’expliquer, il me faut
revenir d'abord un peu en arrière,
pour parler sérieusement d’interférences.
Imaginez que vous soyez avec un ami
au bord d’un plan d’eau,
et que vous fassiez chacun des vagues
mais de façon super synchronisée.
Sur cette simulation je représente
le sommet des vagues en blanc,
et les creux en bleu foncé.
Un peu plus loin sur le plan, les deux ondes
vont se recouvrir,
et ce qu’il va se produire dépend
de l’endroit exact où on se trouve.
Si je suis ici, en plein sur l’axe,
vous voyez que les deux ondes s’ajoutent,
et produisent des vagues et des creux
encore plus importants,
on parle d’interférences constructives.
Mais si je me déplace un peu, vous remarquez
que les deux ondes
n’ont pas parcouru la même distance,
l’une a suivi un chemin plus long
que l’autre,
et elles vont donc arriver décalées.
A cet endroit, le décalage est tel
que le sommet d’une onde va coïncider
avec le creux de l’autre, et réciproquement.
Les deux vont exactement se compenser
et à cet endroit précis,
la surface de l’eau restera quasiment plate.
On a des interférences dites destructives.
Et si on continue à se déplacer
le décalage est tel
que les deux sont à nouveau en phase:
interférences constructives, etc.
Et bien sûr on a toutes les situations
intermédiaires.
Avec la lumière, il peut se passer
la même chose.
Si vous séparez un faisceau lumineux
en deux et que vous le recombinez,
il peut y avoir des interférences
constructives, ou destructives.
C’est ce qui se passe dans la fameuse
expérience des fentes de Thomas Young.
Envoyez un faisceau sur une plaque percée
de deux fentes:
chacune des fentes émettra
une onde lumineuse.
Et placez derrière un écran, sur lequel
les ondes vont pouvoir se recombiner
et se visualiser.
En plein milieu, vous voyez que
les deux ondes ont parcouru
exactement la même distance.
Elles seront bien synchronisées,
il y aura des interférences constructives
et on obtiendra donc une tache bien lumineuse.
Par contre un peu à côté, une des ondes aura
parcouru plus de chemin que l’autre.
Elles peuvent alors se trouver
pile en opposition,
et quand on les ajoute il y a
des interférences destructives.
Aucune lumière ne se trouvera sur l’écran
à cet endroit, il y aura une tache sombre.
Et un peu plus loin, le décalage sera tel
que les ondes seront à nouveau en phase
et en interférences constructives,
et ainsi de suite.
C’est pour cette raison que l’expérience
des fentes d’Young produit
cette alternance de zones lumineuses
et de zones sombres sur l’écran:
on les appelles des "franges d’interférences".
Vous voyez que le phénomène d’interférences
s’explique très naturellement avec des ondes,
mais il parait difficile à justifier
en supposant
que la lumière soit faite de particules.
Voici une illustration de cela.
Si vous bouchez une des fentes, il n’y a plus
qu’une seule onde
et les interférences disparaissent,
on a donc une seule tache lumineuse uniforme.
Mais ça veut dire que dans les zones sombres
où les interférences étaient destructives,
le fait de boucher une fente fait apparaitre
plus de lumière.
C’est difficilement imaginable si on suppose
que la lumière est faite de particules,
mais c’est totalement normal si on imagine
que la lumière est une onde.
Vous comprenez mieux j’espère pourquoi
l’expérience de Thomas Young
fut si convaincante, et persuada
les physiciens de l’époque que,
sans contestation possible, la lumière était
une onde.
Et Maxwell compris plus tard qu’il s’agissait
d’une onde du champ électromagnétique.
Maintenant que vous êtes à l’aise
avec l’idée d’interférences lumineuses,
je vais vous montrer une autre expérience
qui permet d’en faire.
Elle va certainement vous paraitre au début
moins spectaculaire et moins intéressante
que les fentes d’Young,
mais vous comprendrez ensuite son intérêt.
[jingle]
Prenez un faisceau lumineux,
on va dire un laser,
et envoyez le sur ce qu’on appelle
une lame semi-réfléchissante.
Il s’agit tout simplement d’un morceau
de verre sur lequel
on a déposé une couche spéciale, de sorte
qu’environ 50% de la lumière la traverse,
et 50% est réfléchie, c'est un peu
comme un miroir sans tain.
On se retrouve donc avec deux ondes
lumineuses,
ayant chacune une intensité
réduite de moitié.
On va ensuite placer un miroir sur chacune
des deux trajectoires,
pour réfléchir les faisceaux.
Et pour finir, on dispose une deuxième lame
semi-réfléchissante là où ils se croisent.
Pour que ce soit bien clair ce qui se passe,
je vais tracer les deux chemins avec
une couleur différente,
même si évidemment les deux faisceaux
de lumière sont de la même couleur.
On voit que de chaque côté
de la deuxième lame,
il y a un mélange de lumière passée
par le chemin rouge,
et de lumière passée par le chemin bleu.
Dans le cas idéal que j’ai dessiné,
vous voyez
que les deux chemins ont exactement
la même longueur.
Les ondes en sortie seront donc parfaitement
synchronisées
et on aura des interférences constructives.
Ça veut dire que si je place un détecteur ici,
il va capter plein de signal.
Maintenant imaginez que je rallonge
artificiellement
le chemin rouge d’une certaine longueur l.
Je symbolise ça avec une petite boucle
mais c’est quelque chose qu’on sait faire
avec de la lumière.
Si je rajoute juste ce qu’il faut,
l’onde correspondant au chemin rouge
peut être décalée de façon à compenser
exactement l’autre.
On aura donc des interférences destructives,
et aucun signal sur le détecteur.
Et si je continue à rallonger un peu
le chemin,
les deux seront à nouveau en phase,
et ainsi de suite.
En faisant varier progressivement
la longueur du chemin parcouru sur
une des deux trajectoires,
on peut retrouver des variations
sur le détecteur
qui correspondent exactement
à ce qu’on avait
avec les franges d’interférences
dans l’expérience de Young.
Cette expérience, on appelle cela
un interféromètre de Mach-Zehnder.
A première vue, vous vous dites peut-être
que c’est quand même moins spectaculaire
que les fentes d’Young.
Au lieu d’avoir toutes les interférences
d’un coup sur un écran,
il faut faire varier le chemin, enregistrer
ce qu’on a sur le détecteur
et recommencer pour tracer toute la courbe.
Ca peut paraitre plus fastidieux,
et moins joli,
mais vous allez voir l’intérêt très vite.
Avant ça deux remarques au sujet
de ce montage.
La première, c’est qu’on a le même phénomène
qu’avec les fentes d’Young
quand on bloque une des trajectoires
Si on règle le montage pour avoir
des interférences destructives,
donc pas de signal sur le détecteur,
et qu’on coupe un des chemins,
avec un obstacle.
Il n’y a plus qu’une seule onde,
plus d’interférences
et donc un signal apparait sur le détecteur.
Avoir plus de signal en bloquant
un des chemins,
c’est vraiment quelque chose qui n’aurait
aucun sens avec des particules,
mais qui s’explique très bien
avec des ondes.
Mon autre remarque, elle concerne
ce qui se passe
de l’autre côté de la deuxième lame
semi-réfléchissante.
Là aussi on a deux ondes qui ressortent
et interfèrent,
donc si on met un deuxième détecteur,
on imagine avoir la même chose.
C’est vrai, mais il y a une subtilité:
on obtient en fait le même genre
de signal mais opposé.
Quand c’est constructif sur le premier
détecteur,
c’est destructif sur le deuxième.
Il y a une explication logique à cela,
mais je vous épargne les détails.
Bien donc résumons: avec le montage
en interféromètre de Mach-Zehnder,
on a des interférences, et on arrive
à la même conclusion
qu’avec les fentes d’Young: cela montre
clairement
un comportement ondulatoire pour la lumière.
Je vous l’ai dit ce montage à l’air
à première vue moins pratique,
et pourtant on va pouvoir faire
un super truc avec:
lui envoyer des photons un par un!
Quand on fait des interférences, on l’a vu,
la lumière se manifeste vraiment
comme une onde.
Et pourtant on connait d’autres situations
où elle va se comporter clairement
comme des particules,
notamment lors que des atomes individuels
émettent des photons.
Et c’est grâce à ces phénomènes
qu’on peut fabriquer
ce qu’on appelle des sources lumineuses
de photons uniques,
capable d’envoyer des photons un par un.
Je ne vais pas rentrer dans les détails,
mais c’est seulement depuis les années 80,
qu’on sait fabriquer ce genre de source
de façon de plus en plus contrôlable.
Pour les curieux, la première de ces sources,
c’est notamment celle qui a été mise au point
pour les expériences de violations
des inégalités de Bell
qu’ont réalisé Alain Aspect et son équipe,
j’en ai parlé dans mon épisode sur le sujet.
Il existe aujourd’hui plusieurs techniques,
et elles ont en commun
de permettre d’envoyer des photons uniques,
bien séparés,
à un rythme que l’on peut ajuster.
Ça veut dire qu’on peut attendre qu’un photon
soit complètement passé
dans le dispositif avant d’en envoyer
un autre.
Alors vous allez me dire: comment on sait
qu’il s’agit de photons uniques,
et pas d’une onde très faible?
Eh bien voici une expérience qui le démontre.
Prenons une de ces sources photons uniques,
et dirigeons la
vers une lame semi-réfléchissante
comme tout à l’heure.
Et puis plaçons deux détecteurs ici et là.
Eh bien chaque fois qu’un photon
est émis par la source,
un des deux détecteurs va s’activer,
mais jamais l’autre en même temps.
Alors qu’avec une onde, on constaterait
ce qu’on appelle des coïncidences:
les deux détecteurs s’activeraient parfois
de façon simultanée.
Mais là à chaque photon qu’on envoie,
c’est l’un ou l’autre, pas les deux.
L’interprétation de ceci, c’est que
chaque photon passe
soit par un chemin, soit par l’autre.
C’est à dire que quand il rencontre
la lame semi-réfléchissante,
chaque photon a 50% de chance
d’être réfléchi,
et 50% de chance de traverser.
Mais il ne se coupe pas en deux.
Et là si vous vous amusez à boucher
un des chemins,
ça ne changera absolument rien à ce qui
se passe sur l’autre détecteur,
il n’y a pas d’interférences
entre les deux chemins.
On a là une expérience qui pointe vraiment
vers un comportement corpusculaire
de la lumière:
des photons qui sont des paquets
d’énergie individuels,
bien localisés dans l’espace, et qui ont
une trajectoire bien identifiable.
OK, puisqu’on a la certitude que notre source
produit bien des photons individuels,
on n’a plus qu’à envoyer ça dans
un interféromètre de Mach-Zehnder
et voir ce qu’il se passe!
Si on fait ça, en réglant bien la source,
les photons vont passer individuellement
et vont donc, un par un, venir frapper
les détecteurs.
Et ce qu’on va faire, c’est compter
les coups:
combien de fois le détecteur va s’activer
pendant un intervalle de temps donné.
Et si on fait ça suffisamment longtemps,
et pour chaque réglage possible
de la distance l,
on retrouve l’équivalent des franges
d’interférences.
C’est-à-dire que les photons
arrivent un par un,
et en quantité telle que, collectivement,
il finissent par reproduire les oscillations
caractéristiques des interférences.
Ce qu’on constate là, c’est la même chose
que la fameuse expérience
des fentes d’Young avec des électrons
dont je vous avais parlé dans ma vidéo
sur le sujet.
Une construction progressive de la figure
d’interférences, photon par photon.
Là ça commence à devenir troublant,
parce qu’on a une source de lumière
dont on a acquis la conviction
qu’elle envoyait des photons individuels
bien localisés,
avec une trajectoire précise.
Et dans cette expérience on a quand même
des interférences.
Et bien sûr si on bloque un des chemins,
la figure d’interférences disparait
complètement.
Ce sont de vraies interférences.
Ça montre que clairement dans
cette expérience,
le comportement des photons est différent
de ce qu’on avait
quand on plaçait simplement un détecteur
sur chaque chemin.
Les photons sont bien émis un par un,
mais d’une façon ou d’une autre
ils arrivent à produire des interférences.
On peut essayer d’exprimer cette bizarrerie
avec des images:
en disant que chaque photon passe
par les deux chemins à la fois,
qu'il interfère avec lui-même.
Les termes ne sont pas forcément
très adéquats,
mais ils expriment l’idée que quand
le photon arrive dans le dispositif,
il sait d’une façon ou d’une autre
qu’il y a deux chemins accessibles,
et cela influe sur son comportement,
en provoquant des interférences.
Alors que quand on place juste
deux détecteurs
derrière la première lame
semi-réfléchissante,
le photon sait qu’il n’y a pas à faire
d’interférence,
qu’il faut choisir un seul des deux chemins
avec 50% de probabilité.
Tout ça est très bizarre, mais finalement
c’est complètement en ligne
avec l’idée de complémentarité de Bohr.
Cette idée nous dit que le comportement
du photon
va dépendre de l’expérience qu’on fait avec.
De même que la maïzena "sait"
si on est en train de la manipuler
doucement ou vigoureusement, et
ses propriétés en seront différentes.
Eh bien le photon, quand il sort
de la source et arrive dans le dispositif,
il "sait" quelle expérience on va lui faire,
et il ajuste son comportement.
Alors oui, pour simplifier j’utilise
les termes "savoir" ou "décider",
comme si le photon avait un cerveau.
Mais pas besoin d’invoquer de conscience
du photon.
L’appareillage de mesure est là, il a tout
le temps de se signaler au photon,
et d’avoir un impact sur son comportement,
même si on ne sait pas forcément comment.
Donc la dualité onde-corpuscule,
c’est bizarre,
ça nous oblige à repenser notre conception
de la lumière,
mais finalement avec la complémentarité
de Bohr, ça s’explique très bien.
Mais c’est là qu’entre en scène,
John Archibald Wheeler.
[jingle]
Wheeler, c’est un physicien américain,
qui a surtout travaillé
sur la relativité générale,
mais aussi sur les fondements
de la mécanique quantique.
Et en 1978, il a proposé une expérience
pour essayer
de pousser dans ses retranchements
l’idée de complémentarité.
Tout à l’heure, on a vu deux dispositifs
expérimentaux
utilisant une source de photons uniques.
[Dans un cas on utilise une lame
semi-réfléchissante et deux détecteurs.
Et on voit clairement un comportement
de particule.
Dans l’autre on crée deux chemins
qu’on recombine avec une seconde lame,
et on voit clairement un comportement
ondulatoire, des interférences.
L’interprétation usuelle, c’est de d'imaginer
que le photon sait
à quel dispositif il a affaire, et il change
son comportement en fonction de ça.
Dans la première expérience il fera
la particule,
et n’empruntera qu’un seul chemin,
mais dans la seconde, il se comportera
comme une onde,
de manière à passer par les deux chemins
à la fois.
Sauf que là Wheeler nous dit: regardez,
ces deux expériences,
elles se ressemblent quand même beaucoup,
et elles ne deviennent différentes qu’après
la première lame semi-réfléchissante.
Si le photon doit décider de son comportement,
il doit le faire
au plus tard quand il arrive sur la lame.
Soit il décide de faire la particule
et de prendre un seul chemin,
soit il décide de faire l'onde
et de prendre les deux.
Maintenant imaginez qu’on attende qu’il ait
dépassé la lame semi-réfléchissante
pour décider ce qu’on met derrière.
On change l’appareillage au dernier moment,
pour essayer
de forcer le photon à prendre une décision
sans savoir à quelle expérience
on va le soumettre
Et là on se demande bien ce qu’il
va se passer.
C’est assez diabolique comme idée, non?
On appelle cela l’expérience à choix retardé
de Wheeler.
Alors vu comme ça, ça vous parait peut-être
complètement théorique et infaisable,
de changer l’appareillage le temps
que le photon se balade.
Mais je vais maintenant vous expliquer
comment ça pu être fait
par une équipe française en 2006.
Tout d’abord, on va modifier légèrement
la configuration de l’expérience
qui utilisait juste une seule lame.
C’est très simple, au lieu de placer
les détecteurs
juste après la lame semi-réflechissante,
on va placer deux miroirs ici et là
pour renvoyer les faisceaux,
et mettre les deux détecteurs comme ça.
Je vous laisse vous convaincre que
c’est exactement là même chose.
Et notamment le croisement
n’a aucune importance,
les photons arrivent un par un,
n’interagissent pas entre eux.
Et avec ce montage on obtient exactement
les mêmes résultats.
Soit un détecteur s’active, soit l’autre,
un comportement de corpuscule.
Le truc c’est que maintenant ce montage
ressemble quand même furieusement
à l’interféromètre de Mach-Zehnder.
En fait la seule différence,
c’est la présence de la seconde lame
semi-réfléchissante,
qui sert à recombiner
les deux faisceaux.
Donc pour passer d’une expérience à l’autre,
il suffit simplement de mettre, ou ne pas
mettre la deuxième lame.
Et si après l’émission d’un photon,
on attend que le photon ait passé
la première lame pour le faire,
on réalise ce qu’avait imaginé Wheeler:
une expérience à choix retardé
Eh bien ce montage, c’est celui qu’a réalisé
le physicien Vincent Jacques
pendant sa thèse au laboratoire de photonique
quantique et moléculaire,
à l’université de Paris-Saclay.
Je ne vais pas tout vous détailler mais
voici quelques aspects intéressants.
Ce qui tient lieu de seconde lame,
ce n’est pas une vraie lame
qu’on va physiquement mettre et enlever,
mais c’est un dispositif commandé par un
modulateur
qui va bouger très légèrement
une pièce optique,
et permettre ou pas la recombinaison
des deux chemins.
Je vous passe les détails, mais la beauté
du truc, c'est que ce montage permet
de changer la configuration de l’expérience
en seulement 40 nano-secondes.
En 40 ns on passe d'un montage à l'autre,
et on a besoin de ça, puisque, on l’a dit,
on veut pouvoir changer
alors que le photon est au milieu
de l’expérience, après la première lame.
Pour que ça marche, il a fallut rallonger
au maximum cette partie là de l’expérience,
et Vincent Jacques explique dans sa thèse
qu’il s’est placé
dans le sous-sol d’un ancien bâtiment,
de façon à avoir environ 50 mètres de trajet.
alors 50 mètres, la lumière les parcours
en 150 nanosecondes.
Donc si on est capable de changer
le dispositif en 40 nanosecondes,
on peut effectivement décider
de la configuration
bien après que le photon ait passé
la première lame semi-réfléchissante.
Dernier détail, pour que l’expérience
soit vraiment incontestable,
le fait de se mettre dans une configuration
ou une autre
est décidé par un générateur quantique
de nombres aléatoires,
et donc les photons n’ont aucun moyen
d’anticiper ce qu’il va leur arriver.
Et pourtant les résultats de l’expérience
sont clairs:
à chaque fois les photons se comportent
comme prévu.
Si la seconde lame est présente,
même mise au dernier moment,
ils produisent des interférences.
Et si elle n’est pas là, même enlevée
au dernier moment,
ils semblent passer clairement soit
par un chemin, soit par l’autre.
Et là c’est fou, parce qu’avant on pouvait
se dire
qu’au moment de franchir la première lame,
le photon savait quel dispositif
allait le mesurer,
et donc il pouvait "décider" soit de passer
par les deux chemins, soit par un seul.
Mais là l’explication ne tient pas.
Quand le photon arrive sur la lame,
l’expérience qu’on va lui faire
n’est pas encore déterminée,
et l’appareillage est susceptible
de changer plusieurs fois
durant le temps de son parcours
dans les 50 mètres du sous-sol.
Une interprétation naïve, ce serait de dire
qu’au moment de la mesure par le détecteur,
le photon est capable rétrospectivement
de modifier son comportement passé,
et de revenir en arrière pour faire
le bon choix.
Mais ça parait un peu difficile à avaler.
Ce qu’il faut en conclure c’est plutôt
qu’on ne peut pas
s’en tenir à la vision simple du photon
qui choisit en avance
d’être une onde ou une particule
suivant l’expérience.
c'est comme s’il arrivait jusqu’au dernier moment
à maintenir les deux possibilités ouvertes.
Alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut tirer
de cette expérience?
Clairement elle ne remet pas en cause
la mécanique quantique, au contraire,
mais elle permet de pousser
dans ses retranchements
le concept de complémentarité.
Et on voit que l’idée de dualité
onde-corpuscule est vraiment
plus subtile que ce qu’on aurait pu
initialement imaginer.
Le comportement de la lumière va effectivement
dépendre de l’expérience réalisée,
mais d’une façon plus profonde que de dire
que c’est soit l'un
soit l’autre selon les circonstances.
Et sachez, pour compléter, que ces résultats
ne sont pas spécifiques aux photons
et à la lumière, ils ont depuis aussi
été réalisés avec d’autres objets quantiques
comme des atomes.
La mécanique quantique, ça reste
quand même très bizarre!
Voilà c’est tout pour aujourd’hui,
merci d’avoir suivi la vidéo.
Comme toujours, en description, je donne
le lien vers le billet de blog
qui apporte des précisions sur certains
points plus techniques.
Abonnez vous à la chaine,
mettez la cloche tout ça.
Les actualités de la chaine:
ça se passe sur Facebook et Twitter,
et on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos.
A bientôt.
– Sous-titrage: Le Crayon d'oreille -